hello thank you for joining us today we
know how busy you are as parents of
young children particularly during these
times with so much going on in the world
we want to make the session a really
valuable use of your time so we're going
to jump right in
i'm caroline who flexer and i'm the ceo
and co-founder of khan academy kids
and today i am joined by my colleague
dan tue who will be moderating our
questions later
and our special guest renee scott
renee is a long time early educator
and is the early education program
director at stanford university
she's been one of our main curriculum
advisors as we've developed con kids and
renee and i are both parents and we will
be talking about how to keep young kids
engaged and learning at home while many
schools are closed and families are
going through a lot of transition this
fall
we're a non-profit and i'd like to thank
our sponsors bank of america at t
google.org novartis and fastly for their
support of this webinar and our other
distance learning resources
a few other notes this webinar will be
recorded and we'll be sending a copy to
you via email in a few hours
and if you have questions please enter
them in the question box we'll save time
at the end for live q a
so today we'll be focusing mostly on the
youngest children ages two through seven
so preschool through grade one so let's
get started
i am thrilled to have renee with us here
today can you share a little bit about
yourself and your background
sure um thanks caroline i am a lifelong
teacher um i started long ago as a swim
instructor when i was in high school and
just kept on that teaching path
so now um i've taught kindergarten first
grade fourth grade sixth grade
and i'm currently teaching
teachers how to engage in
engage young children with reading and
math
specifically in pre-k and kindergarten
and first grade
and as you mentioned i'm also a mom um
my kids are now a teen and a preteen so
i i've seen a lot of stages with them
wonderful thanks renee
so parents of young children are
typically the ones who are the really
stretched thin
even in the best of times and
right now
in this pandemic they're juggling even
more so on top of work and child care
their heightened health and financial
and medical concerns
and now with school closures
a lot of parents are managing the
distance learning for their young
children what's your big message to
parents as they are getting through
these times and want to keep their
children
learning and developing
yeah so you're exactly right um it is a
stressful time right now trying to
figure out how to juggle things in a new
way
um
and really i think my big message is to
all of you parents out there um you're
already doing a lot
give yourself some grace and give your
kids some grace too
um
it's it's a lot to take on and here's
the thing kids are learning all the time
whether you're teaching them something
or you're just hanging out with them
doing something so there's a pretty good
chance that some of those things that
you're engaged in for example your
bedtime routine
that's in that's engaging in learning
they're learning about time they're
learning about how to reflect on the day
they're using language so today we're
going to spend some time talking a
little bit about what that might
look like and how to insert some
intentional language into how to support
your learning development
it's great
yeah can you give me some examples of
some of these everyday activities um and
how you would use language as you go
through this activity
definitely so
one of the things that i like to remind
myself of is that um when you go to a
preschool classroom a lot of times
you'll notice that kids are working in
some sort of center and they're working
with others
um
and they're we call them sort of work
play centers maybe they're working on a
painting or they're working on listening
to books with a friend or through a tape
recorder
and
so
i like to think about working with young
children even at home
in these ways to think about how to
organize your
organize your day
so for example just looking for
opportunities perhaps to use um your
language and language development and
ask really good questions i'm interested
intentionally during an activity such as
bath time um
it's really a great time to talk about
maybe sensory skills um and fine motor
asking kids hey i wonder how do these
bubbles feel how do they feel to you you
can introduce words like fluffy wet
slippery um those are really great words
to practice and it builds out their
vocabulary um bath time is also a really
great time to make up stories um and
making up stories is brilliant for kids
it helps prep them for learning to read
for learning to write um for starting to
understand things like history and
social studies so it's it's one of those
activities that's really fun when
they're little that just has a ton of
payoff and benefits so if your kids hop
into the bath and they've got a fish and
a frog and just you know say
some really great questions to ask you
know oh what happens you know tell me a
story about fish and frog and then keep
keep the conversation going so what
happens next and then what happens
and tell me more about that so if you
can just keep your kids talking about um
something like that and perhaps use some
of that more difficult language that
they don't know yet and encourage them
to use that in their speech it works
great
um another great example of something
that you're going to have to do anyway
is brushing teeth um i know it can be a
challenge but it's also a great time
maybe to practice math
um
you can set a timer that the kids can
watch they can count the timer down
backwards they can keep track of each
other pounding down backwards counting
forwards maybe they can see how many
times they can hop on a foot before
they're done before they're done with
their brushing um it's also i've heard a
lot of kids sing their abcs while they
wash their hands so these are just some
really easy
but um intentional ways to include a lot
of the vocabulary language and math type
skills that
are really going to help them when they
get back into
the classroom
one that we love at my house is baking
and i think a lot of folks feel like oh
well baking's obvious because it
involves you know measuring and pouring
and things like that
but i think it's easy to forget things
like
um can you count how many blueberries
we're going to put into each of the um
into each of the muffins and put them
into the cups sorting things is amazing
for kids and that's a natural way to get
them sorting
and get them thinking about dividing and
um
grouping and to use mathematical terms
but they're doing it right there at your
kitchen counter maybe and it's something
you have to do maybe you're making
muffins for breakfast or your neighbor
to help them out so those are those are
easy ways to um include that another one
that's great is get out the recipe and
let kids look at it if they can't read
yet that's okay
they can look for words that start with
m they can look for how many ingredients
show them where the ingredient list is
and sometimes they have numbers in front
of them have them count out all the
ingredients those are just some quick
ways to do to to push these things into
what you're already doing
my daughter and i always like to sing
songs um
the other day we had a conversation
she's a little older now but we still
like to talk about song lyrics and we
were singing um the muffin man song
you know the muffin man the muffin and
and i was telling her i used to have
this little boy when i taught
kindergarten who just loved that song
and i said but i always wondered about
the word drury lane i said it's a hard
word to say and drury sounds kind of
dreary and so we had this whole
conversation that included all this
language and that's the kind of um
silly conversation that did
ends up being something that includes a
lot more vocabulary
um
so one more example in this area of just
integrating stuff into into the everyday
one of the things i love is um
thinking about ways to be intentional
about eating maybe not always at the
dinner table but lunch table or
breakfast table is a great time to do
this um
it uh using that time for counting um is
a great example of um putting something
in there quickly so you're handing out
grapes to the kids and ask them how many
grapes would you like
and
have them tell you and then give them
some grapes you can
mix this up you can give them what they
asked for and have them double check and
see if you're right or you can give them
what they didn't ask for and have them
double check and see if they catch you
so
kids really love that aspect of there's
a game in it you know so any can turn
something into a game and make it
playful is is great
great i love hearing your examples
because it's it's
it's comforting to hear that there is so
much learning in terms of language
development and early new mercy that can
just come up in everyday activities and
things so it's not like you have to have
you know you don't have to sit your
child down and in fact if you just sit
your child down and say you know do this
it's probably not nearly as fun and
engaging for them so i love how it's you
know it should always be play-based
for young kids which is how we approach
the learning in con kids
so as an educator what are some
techniques that teachers use to keep
kids engaged and learning through the
day especially as parents you know we're
juggling work and multitasking and
can't always be 100 focused on and
playing with our kids all the time
yeah definitely um one of the things i
mean the reality is there's going to be
periods during the day when your kid you
can't sit down and play with your child
you can't play a game with them you
maybe can't talk to them you're on the
phone um
and the first thing again i want to
reiterate that's okay like it's okay for
your kids to have to hang out and and
entertain themselves for a while if
that's what you need um
everyone's gonna be happier if you're
feeling better about what you're doing
too so give yourself grace there
but one thing that i do like to keep in
mind um and you were you kind of alluded
to this just a second ago caroline about
um motivation is sometimes the second
you you ask a child to do something that
they otherwise might do just for fun
it's not that fun to them anymore so
it's a matter of trying to convince them
that it's their idea right
so
some of the things that um have been
found um actually this always makes me
think of my mentor uh deborah stipek
because she does a lot of research on
motivation with young children and
she really highlighted a few important
things and the ones that i want to talk
about briefly today are um competence
autonomy and care and connection so what
do those mean right so confidence is
just basically kids like to feel like
they know what they're doing so going
back to that grape example
if you um if they're able to catch you
giving them four grapes when they ask
for five they feel really competent and
also you get to see that they know what
they know um a skill and then you it
gives you that indication okay we can
trick we can make this a little more
difficult for them and kids love the
challenge so kind of up the challenge on
them if when you sense that they're
ready for it and they they think that's
exciting
the other thing is language around that
is important so
be careful not to always say good job
good job good job because it's hard to
know what that means so i really love
the response of you did it oh my gosh
you figured that out you noticed that um
so just being really you know specific
oh i saw that you put five blocks all
together in a pile wow
how did you put that together so rather
than just saying good job use it as a
chance to elicit more conversation but
also let them know that you observed
that they did something that was kind of
cool
um
so then getting back to those those
other ideas autonomy is um
just basically giving them choices i
don't know if you've ever heard a pre-k
teacher do this or if you've received
the advice where you
um
you always run the risk of asking when
you just don't give a child a choice you
say something like um do you want to sit
down and color a picture or color up a
picture with me you run the risk of them
saying nope
right so
um kids love to have choice it makes
them feel a little bit more independent
and it gives them some agency so
offer a couple things to them if you
know you're going to be on the phone for
a few minutes you can say here's three
things that you can do what do you want
to start with um do you want to start
with the puzzle or the blocks or the
coloring and let them just pick the
thing and then say when you're done you
can move to the next thing that you want
to do but that way you're giving them
some specific things to do so you're
still putting boundaries around it but
they get to choose and then finally um
the karen connection piece is really
really important um
it's super hard right now because
sometimes
you're trying to listen to a phone call
and you've got your little one going
mommy mommy mommy right and
it feels like you just wanna it's a lot
sometimes to handle all of that at once
and so
it's important to maybe set aside time
to make those points of connection with
your child um one of my favorite things
to recommend and to do is to have a
moment at either at bedtime or bath time
or even first thing in the morning um
where you ask them a few questions just
to tap into their day our favorite thing
at our house is to um
do what we call rose thorn
and bud and so with the rose you asked
them something great that happened that
day that made them feel beautiful um
a thorn is maybe something that was
ouchy that they didn't like very much
and a bud is something that they're
looking forward to um some days we just
do a bud my kids say i'm oh i'm really
looking forward to this thing sometimes
we just do an ouchie because we end up
talking about it for a while and it's
important to make sure that your kids
feel like all of how all of these things
are okay that you're hearing them you
may not even want you don't want to
offer suggestions for how to fix it
necessarily you just want them
to have a chance to tell you what's
going on and kind of get stuff off their
chest little kids need to vent too
so
you're their most um comfortable person
to vent to so that's important because
then they they know that they can um
come to you when they need it but that
it's okay for them to go a little
further during the day and be
independent on their own when you're not
always there it helps that safety factor
so these are important
okay
another part is that um maintaining
routines is really important for young
children why is that and how do you
recommend that parents do that at home
yeah yeah good question um it's really
it can feel really daunting um
and
i want to encourage parents that you you
don't feel like you have to write up a
separate lesson plan for your child on
top of your own plans every day um but
routine at the same time routines are
important they help create a sense of
safety for kids it helps them know
that they're going to be fed at a
certain time and there's comfort in that
they know they're being taken care of
and looked after um it also helps it
helps them to know what your
expectations are of them so if they know
that after dinner their job is to always
help clean up the dishes there's comfort
in that they know that that's something
that they're supposed to do and it helps
lower their anxiety levels which
ultimately helps with things like
meltdowns because they are aware of what
what is coming up and and what their
expectations are
um
so
one thing i want to encourage you to do
is to make your
routine work for you um be in the
evening before you go to sleep or first
thing in the morning when you get up
take a look at your own schedule figure
out when do you when are there times
when you can maybe work with your child
on something and where are the times
when you really do need to have alone
time and you're gonna have to maybe put
some things out for your child to work
on their own and give them those
directions
perfectly fine as well to prompt them
give them something and say hey i want
you to build and when i come back i want
you to tell me about what you built um
so
that that's a nice way to get it or
maybe not i want you to build but here's
some blocks do you want to build and
then let them go with it again you want
it to be their idea but um
but making sure you go back and make
that touch point when you connect with
them again and always come back with a
smile let them know you're happy to be
there with them um and and not add on a
lot to them but just let them just be
with them
um
one thing yeah that we we've i've been
talking to caroline about a little bit
is how to set up a schedule for your
child and so um i know that's something
caroline that that um
is really exciting right now on the khan
academy kids uh programming
yeah we just launched weekly planners
for ages two through seven and um it's
just a template a starting point for
families uh we worked with renee and one
of the most valuable parts of it i think
are just kind of
all the tips in there and ideas for how
to fill your how to fill the time for
early with literacy and math and social
emotional development and it's not that
you have to stick really rigidly to the
planner but it's just you know a place
where um parents can start with a
routine and structure
and most importantly be creative in how
you're thinking remember that you may be
using math or language or literacy in
places that you might not identify so
think think um through what's happening
in your day and just
identify that you can write that on the
planner as that's our list we did it
during teeth brushing this morning and
then you don't have to feel like that's
another check on your list you can make
that anything you want
exactly
great so should we shift now to some of
the questions
from the audience i think dan from our
team is going to be joining us
yep thank you caroline uh before we get
started with the live
questions and answer period there's a
couple announcements that i'd like to
make so first as caroline i mentioned at
the start of this this entire webinar is
being recorded so don't worry if you
missed anything or if you joined late
the recording will be made available
we'll be posting it after this session
and then also excitingly as caroline
mentioned um we did create the weekly
planners and we've actually attached
those as part of this webinar as well so
in our downloadable sections please go
there there are two things that that we
want to share with you the weekly
planners for kids ages two to seven and
also a one cheater quick tip sheet of
some of the topics that renee and
caroline spoke to um just now
and then finally before we get started
with the live question and answers
please start putting your questions on
the question box we have a team of uh
moderators who are kind of servicing up
for me i do my best job to get through
as many of them possible as possible
with renee and caroline okay so shall we
get started
yeah that's great so caroline perhaps
this one's a good place to start with
you we have a great question from laura
laura asks when so much of the
interaction with school is through an
ipad
how can i help my child transition on
and off and so that she can more easily
engage in the actual physical world
yes i
completely understand that when i mean i
think maybe a starting point is what
renee was talking about with the
schedules it's like understanding you
know what's coming from her school and
what's the schedule that they are
proposing
um how much of that is on an ipad and
then maybe you have some other time pe
or something where it's not on the ipad
or maybe the the teacher is actually
leading you through things there
um but something visual is often helpful
for children so that they can kind of
see okay i'm here right now
you know the next block i'm gonna be
doing something else i have to go find a
book or i have to go find something else
in my house
um and i think maybe giving them a
little advanced warning too it's you
know you're about to
transition into the next period let's
let's try this at con kids we also have
some complementary offline activities so
that
um they can use uh
printables um that reinforce the
learning that's in the app too so that
gets them off the screen
those are great ideas i i may i add one
thing quickly um just that often in
preschools on kindergarten classrooms
teachers will use music during
transition times so i'll let you love
you could play it for a minute while
it's time to put one thing away and take
the next thing out sometimes that helps
kids know because it's it goes along
with the schedule and it signals oh
we're gonna change we're gonna shift
gears here let's look at our our
schedule and see what's coming up next
great thank you
we have a question from ruth uh the
question is i have a young kindergartner
and a three-year-old and ruth worries
that when the kindergartner is
potentially falling behind with the
social skills given the distance
learning and and our
shelter in place rules and also she
worries that about potential attachment
issues once the kids have to go back to
school so rene perhaps this is a good
one for you to kind of address how do we
deal with attachment issues and the the
lack of kind of social
interactions or the limited uh
interactions that we have
right right and i think i think that's
definitely a great question it's
something um that even the education
community is trying to think a lot about
um
and this is actually one area where i
might recommend that you try to embrace
technology a little bit more even
to get your kids maybe communicating
with family members or if they have
friends that they might be able to
communicate with the help of another
parent um
and
the parents can be there with you but
just to give them that sense of being
able to play i've seen kids play games
over um like on um
a facebook or a
a zoom type situation and um
they can play um all sorts of games or
they can do jumping jacks together or
something that you that apparent models
for them but in that way they can start
to interact and use some language back
and forth
admittedly it's not the same as if
they're playing necessarily next to each
other but it is helpful another thing i
love is it's a great time to do some
reflecting with your child
there's some really wonderful books um
about social emotional learning and so
it might be a good time especially in
kindergarten
might be a time when they can reflect
back on time experiences that they've
had before that align with what they're
reading in the book and so you can say
oh have you ever felt like this at a
time at a certain time and then you can
actually share your own experience as
well
so it's definitely a challenge um
um but i encourage you to continue to be
creative and and and and let your little
one your little ones kind of help each
other out if they can if they're able to
do that too
great so the next one is is quite a
tough one um i'll let you both answer
this one but caroline someone's probably
good for you and this is one that we
hear a lot and i'm sure this resonates
with with a lot of our audience so cindy
asks i'm on day 4 of school and i'm
already getting uh i don't want to do
school what is a good way to help them
you know get their kids excited to start
the day
yeah that is a tough one especially on
day four
i might start with asking your child
why
um
are you feeling that way today and
it could be a whole host of things it
could be that i don't like sitting here
in front of my computer for so long it
could be i don't know who's in my class
um so i think depending on that
answer um you may have it may trigger
some ideas for you you know for example
if it is the screen like maybe there's a
conversation that you could have with
the teacher to see if there are parts
where
um
he or she does not need to be
logged in and maybe
she can do something else offline or um
yeah i think it's not under
understanding why i don't know renee if
you have other
things to add on this one
that is a tough one that's that's a
great place to start um it's really
understandable that that little ones
might need to
move around a little bit more than they
are
um i would also recommend that you
contact the teacher and explain that
that's happening not necessarily
as a complaint but it's a nice way for a
teacher to gauge how things are going um
our teachers are working really hard to
develop classes that the kids will be
interested in but this is their first
time doing it um as well and so when you
give them feedback it lets them know how
to uh that they might want to adjust and
change for your child um
my other thought is if it's allowed
maybe let your child bring a lovey to
class um or something that makes them
feel comfortable depending on the age of
the child and if that's okay with the
teacher that might be a way to help with
that as well um
or perhaps you could sit with them for
some of the class time um maybe not you
know not all of it but some of it just
until they transition and start to feel
better but i agree caroline i think you
have the the right uh approach in terms
of just trying to figure out what it
might be that's creating
creating that pushback
well i'd like to say there's another
there there's an easier question but the
next one's is quite challenging as well
and i think a lot of parents have this
on their mind um vivienne uh says one
thing that that she's struggling with is
sorry that he's struggling with is that
um both parents are working full-time
they've got meetings on zoom at the same
time and so the gist of the question is
like how should they think about screen
child
screen time for their child um
especially when they are on zoom calls
two three hours a day you know what's
the best way to think about it and the
best way to control the amount of screen
time that they're exposing
yeah i think um you know we're very
cognizant of the
american academy of pediatrics and the
who guidelines around screen time and um
have designed our app to fit within
those constraints on recommendations but
i'd also say
especially during this time when we're
all you know really challenged and
stressed give yourself
you know some forgiveness and and grace
in this area and
i may not look so much at the screen
time i mean you're talking about two to
three hours a day so it's not like
excessive
um but look at the quality of the screen
time what is the screen time bringing to
your child um and how is your child
engaging in that time so it's there's a
there's a huge array of options
obviously and from very passive
experiences where the child you can just
eat them get glazed over and also things
that are not developmentally appropriate
where you're just going to be
overstimulated or not learning um but if
they're using time screen time in a
constructive way so if it's a zoom call
with their teacher and their teacher is
having them
sing or dance or
do activities and they're also getting
some social interaction with their peers
that's very active screen time or if
they're learning you know particular
skills
on a program that's been designed by
educators and has learning goals at the
forefront and
it's really about active minds on
uh learning which you'll be able to see
as you observe your child learning the
screen time and that's those are healthy
ways to be engaging in screen time and
i think you know very good options for
you know when you cannot be
in front of your child 100 of the time
but it does sound like you are trying to
curb the time and i'd say you know also
extending um
you know if your child's really
interested in a certain app or something
like that maybe asking them to take it
offline and draw and tell a story about
about that character or something like
that
i don't know if you wanted to jump in
yeah i think i would one thing um this
may be something parents are already
doing or aware of but do try and have
your kiddo be somewhat near you when
they're on screen time so give them some
headphones so it's not disruptive to
what you're doing but um if it's
possible again i recognize sometimes
it's not possible and that's okay
but it is that that way you can kind of
keep an eye on just what they're what it
is that they're doing um
especially in the case that you have a
kiddo who maybe can switch screens or
switch apps without you realizing it um
and then yes exactly um like caroline
said you you always want to have
something ready for your kiddo to go um
if they want to transition off screens
or you want to try and encourage them to
transition off the screen so having
something out a puzzle that's about that
is part way started a lego activity
that's part way started
um a paint like the paint's ready to go
so they can just get going on it um
that kind of thing at least that way
when they look up there's something else
that they can go to immediately
and might be interesting to them
um
that's a tough one for sure
so i think we have time for one more
question
and renee perhaps you could start with
this one and caroline if you have
anything to add hillary asks my
five-year-old doesn't doesn't choose the
choices i give her
she says no and that she wants something
else even if i tell her she can't have
something else any any inspiring ideas
that you have there
right
um
so this might be a good time to
ask your child ahead of time what are
some choices that you would like to have
so without making the without
promising that she'll get to have them
say you know hey i i wanted some new
ideas for choices that you might like to
do or like to play with um that might
help with just coming up with new ideas
the other thing to keep in mind and be
aware of is it could be that she wants
something else entirely like to spend
time with you and so that might require
a little bit more of a conversation and
and just checking in maybe a few extra
times during the day so letting her know
when you're going to check in with her
and making sure to honor that time so
she knows when it's when it's coming so
you might say these are your choices for
now
i will be back in 15 minutes
and i want to hear all about what you've
been working on or then we can read a
story or then we can watch a show
together whatever is something that she
feels comfortable doing with you could
be more that that she wants that time
i have to say my pre-teen who's 11 right
now has suddenly become really demanding
about breakfast every day which
she's been making herself breakfast for
a really long time and i really think
it's it's her touch point for me she
wants to get up and she wants to be able
to be near me while she's eating
breakfast so even our older kids i think
are looking for that so keep that in
mind that maybe something happening with
your little one as well
cool
any other advice caroline or
no i just had a quick thought of like
building on renee's idea of having the
child come up with a few choices then
maybe you put them all into a box and
then next time you could pick one and
maybe that element of surprise would add
some intrigue to the option
that's a great idea that's a great idea
and and similarly sometimes um you can
rotate like a bucket
a few
toy choices um in and out so today these
are your toy choices but tomorrow we'll
have these toy choices um kind of put
the other ones away so she can't see
them or access them so she um
it's constantly changing up and it looks
a little bit different all the time
right
well um unfortunately that's that's
about all the time we have for the
questions and so caroline i want to
thank you and renee for sharing your
expertise with our audience and as you
can see thank you the audience for
submitting such great questions um and
taking the time out of your busy
schedules to be with us we really
appreciate that
as i mentioned before if you missed
anything don't worry we've recorded this
entire session and we'll be posting that
available online shortly after this
webinar and in fact when you register
you'll automatically be getting this
email with the links to the recording
and then if you need more resources or
you want to learn more you can always go
to conkids.org which is our website for
khan academy kids and there there's a
blue banner at the top that links to our
distance learning resources as well
and we update those things all the time
so please come by and check check by
often
and then before we sign off we want to
ask you to do us one favor there's a
poll that pops up at the very end of
this webinar and asks two important
questions the first is how help us make
future iterations of this session even
better so if you have any questions or
suggestions please put that there
and then secondly you know we're always
looking to create more content to help
you so if the if you have any you know
subjects or topics that you would like
us to dig in deeper please add your
suggestions there as well
so from all of us at khan academy kids
we just want to thank you again and
goodbye